lakovic 19 es una enfermedad causada por
un nuevo coronavirus que fue
identificado en china
se cree que se propaga de una persona a
otra cuando las personas están cerca y a
través de las gotas producidas cuando
una persona enferma tose o estornuda
actualmente no hay tratamiento para la
cob y 19 la mejor manera de prevenir la
enfermedad es evitar la exposición al
virus
una forma de protegerse es lavarse las
manos a menudo lávese las manos
frecuentemente con agua y jabón durante
al menos 20 segundos si no hay agua y
jabón disponibles use desinfectante para
manos debe contener al menos un 60% de
alcohol
evite tocarse el rostro con las manos si
no se las ha lavado otra forma de
protegerse es evitar el contacto cercano
con otras personas
esto incluye evitar el contacto con
personas enfermas
y establezca una distancia entre usted y
los demás quedándose en casa tanto como
sea posible si tiene que salir intenté
mantener una distancia mínima de 6 pies
entre usted y los demás cuando sea
posible para obtener más información
visite el sitio web de los centros para
el control de enfermedades